Third-party libraries can be
serious time savers.
They allow us to do
awesome things on our app
without having to write any of
the functionality ourselves,
and that's a pretty
big convenience.
What's not convenient,
is the code bloat
that they can come with.
I'm David East,
and you can easily
get everything you
need from a library
without all the code bloat.
But let's take a step back.
If you're building a performant
usable mobile app
with a small team and
likely a small budget,
chances are that you are
using a lot of third-party
Android libraries to help you
with the heavy lifting.
This is totally fine.
In fact, it's a good idea.
Many of these libraries
are heavily tested and
have proven to handle
the stress of production
The problem is, though,
you may
have to import the entire
library when you're just
looking to use a subset.
The result of this
is called code bloat.
These extra code paths
turn into overhead
that get shipped with your APK,
and code bloat is no joke.
At the simplest level,
it will increase
the size of your compiled code.
This inflates the APK
the user has to download.
Even more worrisome is the
dreaded 65k method limit.
The Android runtime assigns
a numeric identifier
to each method.
This identifier is 16 bits wide.
So if you have more than 2 of
the 16 methods in your app,
it's not going to compile.
The only way around this is
the new MultiDex solution.
And trust me, you do
not want to do that.
It's pretty much as much
fun as going to the dentist.
Fortunately, there is a tool
in the Android tool chain
that's great for hunting
down un-used code
and stripping it
from your build.
Proguard is a tool that
shrinks, optimizes,
and obfuscates your code by
removing the unused parts.
It also renames classes,
fields, and methods
with semantically obscure
names to make it harder
to reverse engineer your code.
But, that's for another video.
And Proguard is a
seriously sweet tool.
Take a look at the
Google I/O 2015 app.
It's a great app with
a lot of functionality
that uses a lot of
shared libraries.
When doing a release build
without Proguard's code shrinking,
you end up with about
8.4 megabytes of code.
With Proguard on, just 4.1.
And this is especially
awesome because of
how easy it is to set up
this code shrinking.
To turn on Proguard
code shrinking,
simply set Minify Enabled to
true in your Gradle settings.
Then when you build your app,
it will remove all the unused code
for you.
Proguard is not perfect, though.
While Proguard is great at
identifying most used cases,
it's not so great sorting
out other situations,
like code that uses reflection.
This may end up giving you
some false positives
where some code is
removed and some is not,
which means you'll have to
adjust Proguard settings
based on what libraries
you're including.
Some of them may
require special rules
to ensure things all work right.
So do feature you a
favor and take a look
at the documentation.
In fact, head over to
developer.android.com and read
the official Proguard docs.
Seriously,
just go read all of it.
I think it makes for
great bedtime reading.
And when you're done
reading through all the docs
or taking your nap,
come back and watch
the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns videos.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community to share
your Proguard tips
with other developers.
So sweat the small stuff
but don't freak out.
And always remember..
perf matters.